me I was curious what you thought of
this film when John first approached you
with it because you have the distinction
of having been in every piece that John
feature every for sure I'm not in but
yeah I'm in every feature and I love
this movie this was I really loved it
thank you the things I love this movie
particularly because I got to be on the
good side
I go you know usually I was the jerk the
villain the [ __ ] but this time I got
to be one of the good people and I
didn't have to ruin my hair I was one of
the few people in the movie that did not
use hairspray but and I didn't have to I
didn't have to dye it or cut it or do
anything to it so I was very happy with
this role well and Debbie and Colleen
you guys are on the other side of that
equation because you are not very nice
people in this movie and you have tons
of hairspray so tell you about meeting
John and coming to do this film Debbie
and then and then Colleen about being
everybody's favorite nightmare in a
certain way well I met Colleen on the
set really because that they had been
working you had been working before me
and doing all the dance scenes and
everything and I sort of came in close
to the end and so it was an eye opener
but the the kids were so fabulous and
dancing and the music was great and you
know then we then I met sunny and and we
knew each other from polyester because
you had done some of the music in
polyester so we had met each other
before I think we sort of had met
socially yeah I did but to put debbie
and sonny bono together was such a great
for me I was so happy to put them
together on the screen and Sonny Bono
was then the mayor of Palm Springs and
it was kind of amazing he took a role as
a racist you know at which he was not at
all of course but he said right before
it now you're not lying nobody's gonna
run in and one of these scenes in each
[ __ ] are they that's what he was
he thought we had tricked him I just
want to point out nobody eat [ __ ] in
this movie that's true but Debbie Harry
does ask the question is your daughter a
mulatto
I just want to point that out I just
want to point that out
my favorite line that got cut is Ricky
says to link please don't look at my
legs without the benefit of nylons same
could be true for me tonight I'm so
pasty white
among other amazing lines I play Tempe I
want to talk about you guys you guys are
one of my favorite scenes in this film
where PA gets to say let's get naked and
smoke and you just stepped on my line
Jesus you can't say that I can only say
that I think everybody in this room has
probably said that line like five times
in the last two a day kids my son who is
here tonight Christopher kids are in
preschool at the time and whenever I go
to pick them up the parents would say oh
our kids are big fans of yours they walk
around the house saying your big line in
the movie let's get naked and smoke now
I know I always never present in the PTA
Jesus Christ I Romania funny because you
did an article on lonely lady I didn't
know about you before you battle me
because we met at the Berlin Film
Festival and I wrote this piece how much
I love butterfly the movie that where
else can you see Ed McMahon and Orson
Welles together on the screen okay now
you're getting annoying okay what I love
about tonight is that everyone's
embracing me with open arms which is not
like the Golden Goal globe
tribute where they have a restraining
order against me
bastards from lonely lady but you came
and we really hit it off oh we hit it
off and then you said come on let's do
hairspray and I'm like I'm sorry I'm
touring with Sinatra but you flew down
in your plane at the time said here
comes and I said John I don't know from
hippies what the hell you want me to do
so he takes me this shop in downtown
Altima and it gets me this like get up
and gives me how and I'm like hell I'm a
sheltered girl from Queens this is
ridiculous
but I did it right you did it best film
role of my career
[Applause]